on prime crime tonight
[Music]
pure evil strikes the heart of
california
he was able to spot weakness almost like
a predator which this guy
is make no mistake the man who stalked
and attacked
dozens of victims for years
on october 29 1977
our horror movie became reality but the
story
isn't over yet does that mean that there
are not
other crimes out there absolutely not
good evening everybody i'm jesse weber
and welcome to prime
crime tonight this is where we do a
deeper dive into those especially high
profile and memorable true crime cases
tonight one of the most prolific serial
rapists and murderers
of all time
that's the voice attributed to the man
who terrorized the sunshine state
for over 10 years a campaign of
burglaries assaults
rapes and murders spanning multiple
counties
gun sales went off the charts ammunition
was sold out of
gun stores women were signing up for
self-defense classes
hardware stores ran out of locks because
people were locking their doors
they're locking their windows this
unknown assailant would come to have
various names
but his most renowned title as the
golden state killer
the suspected golden state killer the
notorious golden state killer
the case remained unsolved for almost
four decades
but thanks to the tireless work of
investigators and journalists like
michelle
mcnamara who brought the story back into
the spotlight
a breakthrough in 2018 law enforcement
plugged dna material taken from a crime
scene
into a website called jed match which
compares the genealogical data of family
members
they then had to take that common
ancestor
and find all of the descendants of which
there were hundreds
knowing that one of those descendants
if they had all of them was probably the
golden state killer
the genetic profile led to a then 72
year old living in the sacramento
suburbs
dna secretly obtained by authorities
from the suspect's car
and trash matched the killer on april 24
2018 police arrested joseph
james d'angelo joseph james deangelo
has been called a lot of things by law
enforcement
he's been called the eastside rapist
[Music]
he's been called the visalia ransacker
the original night stalker and the
golden state killer
today it's our pleasure to call him
defendant deangelo would end up
confessing to his crimes
victims and their loved ones were
finally able to confront their tormentor
do you remember raping me
do you remember holding a knife to my
throat as you stuck your disgusting
penis in my mouth
what i really wanted to do was to bite
your penis off your body
but that's not the end in fact it might
be the beginning
because we're about to delve into how
the golden state killer committed these
crimes
what his motivation may have been why he
was able to avoid capture for so long
and what's next for him d'angelo is
believed to have started in the early
70s with a series of burglaries earning
him the name
the visalia ransacker but what began as
peeping through windows sneaking into
homes and stealing items
would soon turn into murder beginning
with the killing
of claude snelling d'angelo fired two
shots hitting my dad
he then turned the gun on me as i was
down on the ground
my only thought was this is it
and put my head down expecting him to
kill me
instead he started kicking me in the
head and face then ran off down the
driveway
this would evolve into a series of
sexual assaults
as the east area rapist he kidnapped me
from my bed
he raped me repeatedly
he sodomized me he forced oral
copulation
that is an escalation from when you're
peeping outside someone's window or
digging through their trash can
to actually invading their spaceship the
longer they're out there and practicing
this
remember it's practice they're
practicing every time they're learning
uh they're becoming more and more
skilled sadistic yet deliberate patterns
developed of d'angelo as well
from covering tv sets stacking dishes on
the backs of his victims
to aggressively tying them up after four
hours of being tightly bound
debbie experienced numbness for months
in her hands
then there were the phone calls
authorities believe d'angelo may have
been repeatedly contacting the police
and his victims
he would prey on the victims both before
the crime and
after the crime reaching out to them
sometimes to let them know
you know that he was still there one of
the survivors of the east area rapist
worked with police and taped two
chilling calls she received
on january 2nd 1978
this would be a hallmark of the caller
asking for someone else in the house
or just hanging up but later in the
night
he called back
this all goes back to him pulling the
strings on the individuals
and and it's part of his fantasy i would
imagine
i'm sure that he probably became
sexually aroused when he did this
okay
i think joseph d'angelo um is just
an absolute sociopath i i don't doubt
he's the one that made the phone calls
i think he uh relished and thrived
on his ability to terrorize people there
even was an evolution of his victims
he started by targeting women including
teenagers
i have a full second half of my life
ahead of me
and you've got what you got
however 13 year old mary needed justice
he then would move on to brutally
murdering couples
like charlene and lyman smith we were
told what had happened
we were in stunned shock
it was a hole in our lives that would
never be filled
why the change in victims maybe as a way
for deangelo to
toy with authorities the police also
taunted trying to discover who this
killer was
and taunted and said he changed his mo
and said we believe that this
individual is very weak because he does
not attack men it's only women who are
weak
and later on he changed his mo to do
that soon after
they had made that statement which is
interesting considering d'angelo himself
had worked as a police officer for six
years
in the communities of exeter in auburn
possibly giving him the skills
to avoid capture one of his partners who
said he was assigned to the burglary
unit
and he was the one who ultimately did
the follow-up investigations so
if you committed the crime you're doing
the follow-up investigations you can
make evidence
easily disappear would seem that in many
cases he went to
lynx to clean up behind himself not to
leave
a lot behind i think that that was one
of the reasons uh that
you know you had an indication early on
that you're not dealing with somebody
that's necessarily
new to this a closer look at the attacks
may have provided clues to his
background as well
there's any number of stories about what
he was
telling people to do he's very verbal he
would tell people what to do
specifically
at the scene and he could get their
attention i mean let's just think about
it any law enforcement
personnel that are on the street they
give you specific
lawful directions the more violent the
killing
i think that the individual may have
triggered something within him
maybe they were not as compliant
remember this goes back to this
idea that i'm going to give you a lawful
order and by god you better follow it
despite some leads investigators just
couldn't pin down their suspect
visalia detective bill mcgowan almost
caught the ransacker while he was
prowling a neighborhood
but narrowly missed a shot fired at him
he jumped the fence
and quoting my dad screamed like a woman
and then
fired at the light the bullet hit the
flashlight
instead of the intended target my dad
the case
went cold again the question is could
d'angelo have been caught
sooner for instance he was fired off the
force in 1979
after attempting to steal a hammer and
dog repellent
yet this was not reported to the east
area rapist task force
in all investigations there are going to
be mistakes along the way
this one i believe is prominent the fact
that he was fired for stealing such
peculiar items
the police were looking in a different
direction
only later on when he was profiled as
somebody who was in the police and
military
that would have been a great opportunity
for them to say what police officers
were fired within a certain amount of
time
one argument is that investigators maybe
could have done more
there were two double homicides in the
same neighborhood
in the same with the same motive and
this followed
an attempted double homicide in the same
neighborhood
let's all be clear cooperation between
communities
would have undoubtedly stopped d'angelo
virus from spreading
communities the various counties where
the crimes were occurring
weren't really communicating with each
other to let each other know
what they needed to know in order to
pursue the investigation
then again forensic science and
investigative tools
were not where they are today even just
a few years ago we would need say for
instance
a quarter to a dime sized uh you know
sampling of blood in order to do dna
jesse now we're talking about dead skin
cells at this point in time you know
everybody talks about touch dna touch
dna
you know lord only knows what he
actually left behind there was a lot of
physical contact that was going on with
him
as much as people might want to be an
armchair quarterback and look back and
say what could we have done differently
i would say this
again it is a miracle that we caught him
it was
incredible police work over the course
of 40 years
and it was really only because of the
advent of genetic ideology
that we even got to this point you have
to remember that
for years people have debated is he even
alive or dead
when we come back in a twist that many
never expected
the golden state killer spoke out to his
victims
i've listened all your
statements
[Music]
[Music]
i used to wonder why i was chosen to be
his victim
it used to keep me up at night it was
the only question i had for him
why whether you call him the east area
rapist
the original night stalker the visalia
ransacker
or the golden state killer joseph james
deangelo was captured after 40 years
but what happened next surprised many
let's get more into the mind of d'angelo
one of the most disturbing aspects of
this case is that during and
after these heinous attacks he was able
to live in plain sight
enjoying the time with his family while
his victims were either still suffering
from trauma
or were forced to move on without their
loved ones it's not surprising that a
serial killer
is someone that appears to be just a
normal member of society
after all in order to get away with
these crimes
they have to kind of blend in they have
to be the kind of person that no one
would suspect
making this even stranger there appears
to be a five-year gap in the 80s when
deangelo
seemingly paused his crime spree all of
a sudden he was off the grid
and one thing that we can possibly
attribute to that is we know his oldest
daughter
was born in 1981 so he has three
daughters who were all being born
during that period of time so i think he
stepped up into his role
of fatherhood and took a break joe was
kind and loving
he played games with me
joe out of anyone in my life has always
been my favorite person
i always wished he were my dad they can
compartmentalize that
where they're not going to do harm to
those individuals that they quote
unquote love
they're going to take it out and you
don't know what the trigger mechanism is
either
for why they suddenly decide at some
moment tom
i'm going to go rip this person to
absolute shreds but in 1986
he struck again possibly for his last
time
raping and murdering 18 year old janelle
cruz
deangelo's last known victim the family
and relationships of d'angelo have
themselves been a source of study
with some wondering if this played a
role in his desire to rape and kill
i do more or less blame our father in
part
he was a stern military career man and
also a womanizer
he was also responsible for causing
abuse in our family
mainly being hard on joe and her mother
both mental and physical abuse was
usually directed to them
we know that he witnessed his sister at
seven years old being
being raped and seeing his sister as a
victim
i think that it could have been a
projection of having somebody else there
witnessing a rape witnessing a
um an assault or a battery of of some
type in order to deflect the feelings
that he had what he when he went through
that in his personal life
i believe that that was just another way
to assert his power over them he left
them alive obviously with the burglaries
and the rapes
and it was his way to get that power
over women again and i think it was due
to the loss
of the relationship with bonnie bonnie
altson
d'angelo's ex-fiance she had broken up
with him and maybe he couldn't get over
it
in 1978 one victim eerily recounted how
her attacker
would continually scream out i hate you
bonnie in court deangelo's ex made a
stunning entrance
while not permitted to make a statement
herself one survivor
spoke on her behalf as just a teenager
50 years ago
she broke her engagement to you when she
realized that you would become
manipulative
and abusive when you thought you could
kidnap her
and force her to marry you even a gun
pointed at her face
could not make her choose you when she
saw who you really were
she was done with you i can see that
i hate you bonnie was a result of your
frustration
because you lost control over her
deangelo didn't end up fighting the
charges against him
but instead pled guilty to dozens of
felonies including
13 murders as well as admitting to
nearly 50 rapes and other crimes he
wasn't charged for
all in exchange for taking the death
penalty off the table
he does have family he has children he
has nieces
that he still seems to have a
relationship with
he may have been motivated by that
relationship
to at least take just an ounce of
responsibility
but the other part of it is that you
know people think that well he just got
sick and tired of being in the county
jail
and he knew he was going to go to prison
and so maybe he just felt like he can
move on and get his
his new home set up and
uh you know live out his days in the
state prisons deangelo would have one
final surprise
after the powerful victim impact
statements delivered during his
sentencing
he decided to address the survivors
i've listened all your
statements
each one of them
[Music]
and i'm really sorry
everyone ever
thank you john i sat there in that
courtroom and um was somewhat surprised
that he decided to get up and give a
statement but uh
it was an empty apology it was
essentially like
that's it that's what you have for 40
something years you terrorized people
and you got up and just said i'm sorry
there was much reason to doubt the
sincerity of d'angelo
considering while he appeared to behave
weak and frail in court
videos released by the government
showing him moving and
exercising in his jail cell tells
something
entirely different oh there's no
question he was faking it i mean
you know from the day before his arrest
when he was zipping around on a
motorcycle
uh to the day after his arrest when he
was in court in a wheelchair the man
is a sociopath everything that he does
whether he's you know 45 years old or 74
years old
is designed to benefit himself so from
the day of his
arraignment the very first day in court
until the day that he was
you know convicted and sentenced was was
a complete
master manipulation almost as though he
is putting on a
show for everyone who's watching and in
a sense he feels like he's getting over
on people it's almost a joke to him
ultimately judge michael bowman
delivered the sentence
accounting for all the evils in
deangelo's life
d'angelo is sentenced to a total of 11
life without the possibility parole
sentences plus an additional life
sentence
plus an additional eight years this is
the absolute
maximum sentence the court is able to
impose under the law
and while the court has no power to make
a determination of where the defendant
is imprisoned
the survivors have spoken clearly the
defendant deserves no mercy
but there's more after the sentencing a
curious thing happened the government
conceded d'angelo
could be linked to more attacks
does that mean that there are not other
crimes out there
absolutely not i don't believe we will
ever know the magnitude of what mr
d'angelo did
sitting here today i can say as the d.a
in sacramento
i'm not aware of additional crimes that
we have evidence to link him to now that
doesn't mean we wouldn't
keep looking we go back to that pause in
86
and there were a couple other little
smaller pauses during that period of
time
i can't imagine that he was not
up to something and this is a vast area
you know for all we know
he could have assumed an identity uh he
you know might be carrying some other
nom daguerre
out there and and perpetrating the
crimes uh
to kind of feed this lust that he has at
the end of the day
i'm just very grateful that this person
this despicable human being
he's gotten what he deserves and that is
to die die in prison
as a convicted serial killer i'm going
to sing a little song it's really short
it's what my grandpa we used to sing
when we would say goodbye to somebody
and it goes like this bye bye
joe bye bye bye bye joe
don't cry and joseph d'angelo
and his mother can go straight to hell
the golden state killer is behind bars
and while the pain and loss that this
man inflicted on so many is difficult to
imagine we can take comfort in knowing
that advancements in science and
technology
may prevent anything like this from
happening ever again
that's all we have for you on prime
crime tonight give us your comments on
joseph james d'angelo on twitter and
facebook with the hashtag prime crime
tonight
thank you for joining us and until next
time be safe
[Music]
you